la traditionnelle gay pride joue les
records et des sans doute par le soleil
près d'un demi million de personnes dans
les rues de paris pour ce défilé marqué
cette année par la volonté de combattre
toutes les discriminations et pour la
première fois les politiques avaient
envie de s'afficher les grands partis de
gauche à l'écouté de la communauté
homosexuelle avec en tête
bertrand delanoë habitués c'est vrai de
cette manifestation
mais j'avais encore un maire de paris
n'avait conduit de bout en bout ce
mouvement dans votre thé cochard marie
pierre cassignard et leurs anciens 80
ans la discrétion est de rigueur et les
homosexuels et c'est à peine toléré une
manifestation syndicale
trente ans plus tard ils sont cinq cent
mille à défiler à la gay pride et ce
sont les hommes politiques qui couvrent
d'après eux de façon de parler et se
sont placés en tête du cortège avec dans
le rôle du maire légitime d'astronomie
pride ils m'ont élu ce qui veut dire que
les parise et des parisiens sont des
gens qui aiment la liberté et qui savait
lire leur met son projet
quelle que soit son identité dans le
rôle du plus ancien le candidat vert à
la présidentielle succès à la première
gay pride
on était très isolée à l'époque je me
réjouis maintenant que tout le monde y
est je crois que quand on demande rurale
où tout le monde se précipitera pour
avec de prime abord ionienne et dans le
rôle du pénitent l'un des rares
représentants ed
le dernier
m on aurait dû être là avant le match
mais moins que les erreurs comme celle
de
mais après on est le bal ce qu'on peut
rentrer récupération ou pas les
homosexuels sont plutôt satisfaits
il y avait un pouvoir un pouvoir
électoral chez les homos
présent dans les délais du patronat la
pénombre
o o nt mot égalité
le pacs n'est qu'un des bouddhistes il
faut encore progresser notamment sur les
droits parentaux
je pense que c'est vachement important
je pense que les personnes homosexuelles
sont capables de donner de l'amour aux
enfants au même titre que les vétérans
c'est clair avoir des enfants pouvoir
ajouter pouvoir se marier avoir les
mêmes droits que les hétérosexuels
bref supprimer toutes les
discriminations tel était le mot d'ordre
pour que la société évolue